la guerra en ucrania ya está reflejando
graves consecuencias a nivel económico
en el país el banco mundial estima que
la economía retrocederá un 45 por ciento
este año algo que ha provocado el cierre
de negocios y ha asfixiado el número de
importaciones y sobre todo de
exportaciones para exportar nuestro
gobierno tiene derecho a limitar las
exportaciones debido a ciertas
condiciones como ahora para regularlas y
limitarlas en el caso de algunos
productos para poder garantizar la
seguridad alimentaria de ucrania este
producto destacó aunque el daño no se
limita el país asediado ucrania es un
exportador global de productos agrícolas
como el trigo cuya producción se ha
visto afectada por la guerra tanto por
la siembra como por la destrucción de
infraestructuras como carreteras algo
que ha dejado vacías las estanterías de
los supermercados de muchos países que
dependen de estas exportaciones
de la guerra en ucrania nos ha afectado
tanto que ya no podemos trabajar antes
podía conseguir sémola todos los días
entre 50 o 60 kilogramos y hacer pan
la guerra ya no podemos encontrar ni
siquiera un poco de sémola para trabajar
es una gran crisis somos ha transmitido
el ver junto a ucrania rusia verá un
retroceso del 11 por ciento en su
economía como resultado de las sanciones
impuestas por occidente en el plano
global los economistas advierten que en
asia central la guerra generará el doble
de daño económico que la pandemia de
kobe 19 daños que aún podrían aumentar
si el conflicto no se detiene